as I understand it this was brought to
you by Mark Ruffalo so what stage was it
in at the time that he brought it to you
and what were your initial conversations
with him like in terms of what kind of
movie you both wanted to make yeah the
the project mark brought the project to
me in 2017 there's only a year after the
New York Times expose by Nathaniel Rich
broke in 2016 and they already had
there was already a first draft of the
script they were really moving very
quickly they felt a great sense of
relevance of this story
this ongoing battle and and but Marc and
I I think talked about where the script
was at that time and felt that we could
probably go deeper a little bit and that
there were issues about the complex
dynamic of Rob a lot in relationship to
the firm Taft law firm in Cincinnati and
the dynamics between his managing the
managing partner who ultimately a
managing partner the Tim Robbins plays
Tom Terp and just what it meant for a
defense for him to turn around and start
to take on a plaintiff's case and
challenge a chemical company like the
Pont who they really considered like you
know a brother to the kind of clients
that they that they represented and so
by the time my schedule opened up it was
a year later and I brought on a new
writer Matthew Carnahan was busy
directing a film of his own and I
brought on this amazing guy Mario Correa
we went we all went to Cincinnati and
met all of the principal people in the
story and it really began sort of with
fresh eyes on it and Marc joined us and
Rob a lot sort of chaperoned to the trip
from Cincinnati to Parkersburg West
Virginia we went to Wilbur's farm we met
Wilbur's brother Jim a lot of the people
who actually appeared in the film but
were even more of them were present
through the entire process of making the
film and it really became
our touchstones for the specificity of
the story and the details and the
nuances and what we were trying to
trying to do Christine you've been
producing Todd's movies basically from
the beginning since poison on a film
like this it's is it different working
on a film like this with him that does
originate with someone else as opposed
to the original material I mean at what
point in the process do you come in and
how do you see your role as far as
facilitating the movie and his best work
I mean you know in many ways it's it's
all the same because we are working hard
together to bring you know the the
script which you know is is a blueprint
for what will end up on the screen but
and and but not you know there's there's
so much that has to happen to it as Todd
you know alluded to so you know we
started the second todd was interested
in it killer myself and Pam Koffler
started figuring out what that process
would be and it wasn't easy I mean you
know this when I think about the real
challenges of this particular film a lot
of them were whether it was the longest
winter I think any of us had ever seen
ever in our lives in any place and and
and really just trying to make sure well
you want one of the one of the benefits
I mean I remember one of the last times
I was here with Todd was for Carol I
which we shot in Cincinnati but we were
hiding Cincinnati and this movie we get
to not hide Cincinnati because it
actually took place there which was
really great so uh anyway it was now it
never lost track of your question but
but I guess the challenges really were
you know these were real people um Rob a
lot was on our set every day almost and
if he wasn't on our set he was available
you know by telephone to ask questions
which we did all the time
so there was a lot of responsibility for
this story and how did you feel that
shooting in those real locations
informed the look of the film well I had
a lot of vested interest in this I went
to university 45 minutes from there at
Ohio University so I knew the area and
we had shot again in Cincinnati for
Carroll and even my physical condition I
have to admit is due to heavy metals and
contamination so a story like this I
really wanted to participate in I'm
curious what the sort of guiding
principles were for you in terms of the
cinematography it's one of the things I
love about this movie is I really like
the kind of restrained observational
style you came up with and yet it still
somehow really draws you in I mean well
that has a large do to Todd I mean it's
always going to film school each film
because the references and the stylistic
considerations because we're always
looking for the visual metaphor for the
story and he looked back to the 70s and
looked at Alan Pakula and Gordon Willis
and looked at those films that were so
you know they're the paranoid thriller
genre and how restrained the camera was
and how Gordon Willis always allows you
to participate with the image it wasn't
this subjective aggressive look in so we
were always very conscious of though
that idea and then you know you explore
those ways of doing it and hopefully it
works it gives kind of a respect to the
audience for them to participate with
the image not like you know forcing them
that feel something it seems to me like
this would be a very challenging movie
in the sense that it's very information
based there's a lot of information you
have to get across the audience but you
also have to draw them itto keep the
emotional thread going and everything
like that so how do you keep that
balance going in the editing it's a hard
question I think you just I'm going to
just go at it and you just
how much because it's it's a tricky film
because it takes place is a lawyer
looking through papers how do you make
that interesting and exciting but so
it's just the amount of information you
give you have enough repetition so you
get it but then you just need to keep
the information you have to find out
with the audience with time with with
Rob and that's what we try to do we try
to sort of balance like okay we can say
twice but then he needs to find out we
can't repeat the volume of information
has to be spread out to the phone and so
that's what we try we tried to do and he
tried to keep it again I we watch i
watch a lot of the the 70s film that has
that kind of the pace is very specific
and the tension and how much you you
withdraw how much you show and that's
basically what we try to do and then so
there's a musical aspect to that we try
and then when Marcelo came in he just
becomes so everything we're trying just
kind of elevates and that's basically
were we doing in the cutting room and
Fonzie you know we work with temp music
while while cutting and it starts to
help structure and kind of provide sort
of examples of what the emotional kind
of component will be in the final role
of the composer and he tried this piece
of piano music during the exact piece
discovery montage is what we were how we
refer to that sequence and it was this
long improvisational piece of piano that
was an unexpected choice I'd really I
knew we needed a continuous piece of
music for that for that section
it couldn't be too aggressive but if it
dissipated too far you wouldn't feel
like it was being bracketed and there
was a through line to it and this piece
of music was was really you know it
evoked things that we just didn't really
know what we were gonna do until it we
heard it and it caught in it then it
provided a kind of accidental template
for how to cut the rhythms of it and
then we brought in Marcelo who had a
very short
Joost amount of time to do this very
complicated and demanding score which
went from everything from solo piano to
symphonic you know there was strings
involved and the string quartet I'll let
you describe it further but that piece
of music was one remarkable sort of
surprised that Fonzie first found some
of the piano music and he reminded me a
lot of like David Shire score for the
conversation and I'm curious what some
of if you were thinking about movies
like that or if that's just coincidence
we were thinking more of the style of
those films not necessarily we didn't
talk about the music of those films but
rather the atmosphere of those films I
think that was more what we were looking
for and I think it's interesting this
particular sequence that thought is
talking about because the entire film
thought really was very adamant about
the music and the instruments always
being very processed and almost like in
fact it that's how he described it like
how the instruments should be just never
pure in any ways except for this one
very long piece this long sequence of
the explanation which is solo piano in
its pure piano there's no effects
there's no nothing and it's just a
single performance that we shape
together and it was it was wonderful and
it was almost like the closest that I've
had of marrying my own original love of
jazz and improvisation with scoring
because although I wrote a piece we then
kind of hammered it out together with
Fonzie with me playing and like okay we
like this we're done and we kind of put
it together like that and it was a very
riveting thing to do for a composer and
kind of this real-time collaboration
like this is it's really Annie being a
pianist was just kind of everything
comes together and and being able to
react and and sometimes start would be
telling me things like on the headphones
as I was playing and it was really kind
of like an actor being being you know
not kind of exactly like an actor being
you know directed and and it's really
and any it comes from the loudest most
busiest part of the score we then cut to
this thing and only honestly as far as I
can tell
reigns would really think of of having
this kind of the climax of the film in a
certain way be sure understated
musically and at the same time it it
puts it underlines that scene in a way
that only really by having less we could
have done it by just having a simple
piano the sound I want to thank you all
for coming and talking about this movie
with us